Oh India bans Tick Tock the United  States is thinking again about  potentially Banning Tick Tock and people  keep reaching out to me to say should I  even get started on Tick Tock is it even  worth it what if they just ban it I just  wasted all my time listen the ability to  make short form content is here to stay  that is a skill that will serve you for  the next couple years and you should  learn how to do it YouTube shorts is a  thing and next month they're going to  start actually paying you a lot of the  big tick tockers they're gonna move to  YouTube because they can make money  doing it Instagram reels is a thing  Facebook reels is a thing the ability  for you to learn you to learn how to  make short form content that wins is a  skill set that is required in 2023  marketing whether they ban Tick Tock or  not that is a skill that you need to  learn and can benefit from otherwise  your competitors will